this block in downtown Beijing was
designed to project a modern image of
China surrounded by cafes shops and
offices a two-bedroom apartment here
once cost upwards of one million dollars
but in recent years prices have dropped
we haven't made much profit this past
three years there are more new houses
and the many people think there will be
more customers but that isn't the case
the reality is the vacancy rate is
relatively High and the sale rate is low
everyone is waiting and watching the
Chinese government says property prices
will recover this year but Jin dungley
isn't convinced he says the sector
suffered because of the pandemic but
that hasn't been the only problem
in 2021 Beijing cracked down on dead
ridden real estate developers with the
aim of preventing a market bubble the
measures sparked a liquidity crisis
which left many buildings unfinished and
thousands of buyers in the Lurch
authorities are now scrambling to prop
up the industry which contributes about
a quarter of China's GDP
the government's intention was to bring
down the leverage not to kill the market
since the measures were taken in such a
hasty Manner and it was so strict then
the market was in the worst recession
since 1990s and in addition to that
there was covet restriction so the
overall sentiment over the market was
just become way more pessimistic than
the market than the government intended
to intended to see
in December Beijing ended almost three
years of harsh zero covered policies it
also eased lending restrictions for
property developers lowered mortgage
rates and ended housing ownership caps
in some cities but consumer confidence
remains low
in big cities like Beijing the cost of
an apartment is typically much more than
one young person can afford so parents
and often even grandparents pull their
entire life savings to help buy one but
in recent years many families have held
off choosing instead to keep their money
in the bank
analysts expect property prices to stop
declining this year but say it may take
years for the sector to fully recover
y the big challenge is reversing
people's mindsets he says many believe
investing in property just isn't as
profitable as it used to be
Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing